we search [ __ ] babies here we
complain about so much we don't know how
good we have we don't know how good we
have it and people won't know because i
didn't know bro until i started
traveling the world
and i'd be in dope-ass places but i'm
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] all right i won't go
back home i went to so many and then the
closest place i
i almost got a crib in sydney australia
at one point right because it's so cool
i bet you you were slaying out there
it was nice out there bro the weather
was dope bunch of iggy azaleas running
around yeah all of that is she australia
yeah okay but the people are so [ __ ]
nice and when you're traveling different
countries
when you go to english-speaking
countries it's just a better vibe you
know what i'm saying right so it's all
like this is kind of dope but then like
when covet happens to see character
comes out in hard times right
so kovit came out right
you're looking at europe looking at
australia these [ __ ] are on
martial law especially in australia
australia was really bad all bad so i
was like [ __ ] that we free here i don't
care about people complaining neighbors
snitching on themselves out there was
crazy yeah bro we and they don't got
guns yeah like crazy
look i just i just realized this during
the past two years
we're the only country who have a
constitutional right for our citizens to
carry weapons yeah that wide spread
everybody got them people don't realize
that they don't know that [ __ ] they're
taking that away from the canadians
right now oh i didn't even know they had
guns trudeau just uh
banned handguns or is proposing it and i
think [ __ ] that
setting up uh some sort of like turn-in
date where you have to turn in your
handguns or something i don't know if it
passed i'm not like super i just i i
just know that like it was it's being
proposed you gotta come get it for me
yeah and and that's the thing with like
the gun violence thing is like i think
i do think that an 18 year old shouldn't
be able to go to the store and buy two
ars without [ __ ] any sort of
conversation or hey what are your
what what's going on why do you need
these guns like there should be some
sort of background check for certain
things but
i also think we have to understand that
we're in america
this is the only place in the world like
this place and unfortunately for the
good for the bad
this is our culture
and our culture is we
have guns and if and there's more guns
here
then people buy a whole lot so the
realistic expectation to ban
and i do think like again i think there
should be like comprehensive
background checks for certain weapons
like like what like i think if if like
that kid in uh you don't you've all day
like he turned 18 and he went to the
store and bought two ar-15s no checks
just
wouldn't cop two guns
yeah i mean
i don't know if i like that that
extensive background check [ __ ] because
it's like
when does it stop or even or even like
how about a course
how about like that's fair how about a
voice
like you need a license to have an ar-15
if you want an assault weapon you got to
have a license you got to go through
schooling
like if if i'm if i'm a 16 year old but
that's not the that that won't be the
route to the problem because it's not
about how accurate you can shoot it's
about your temperament your personality
you know what i'm saying or if you have
any mental illness and [ __ ] like that
because then the [ __ ] that be
going out doing dumb [ __ ] is not how
proficient you are yeah and maybe those
dumb [ __ ]
we'll see damn getting that gun
is i'm lazy i like to [ __ ] play call
of duty all day and jerk off in my
parents bedroom
i am not trying to go down to the
[ __ ] gun department and and go
through six hours of of machine gun
class yeah i wouldn't either but i think
this will like but i would do it like i
would go through that for a gun like
because you're a responsible gun owner
like me too but i don't want to have to
i don't want the government telling me i
have to do [ __ ] i'm i think it's just
certain guns though like i think if you
get a handgun that's that's something
that i think you should be able to get a
handgun and actually kill a lot of
people too i i feel you you get you get
a clip with a drum it's got as much
rounds as any other rifle you know what
i'm saying here's the thing bro
when when would it stop if we allow that
it's a slippery slope opens up the door
for tyranny i mean listen i don't
disagree with that but i just think that
there has to be
a course man like i'm not mad at a
course especially how about this if
you're like under the age of 30 or 25
let's say you're like a 21 year old kid
like you should
we should know you know how to operate
this thing before you get it you know
what it is if that's the case they
should do the same with law enforcement
i agree it shouldn't be it shouldn't be
a 21 year old cop